des procureurs italiens réclament une
lourde peine de prison pour un résident
d'origine italienne établie depuis une
trentaine d'années attentes de bay dans
le nord de l'ontario
la police italienne soupçonne l'homme de
66 ans de diriger une cellule de la
mafia calabraise décrite dans un récent
rapport d'europol comme l'une des
organisations criminelles les plus
dangereuses du monde
alain gravel pendant que les projecteurs
au québec sont dirigés sur le clan
rizutto plutôt content d'être revenu au
canada en ontario la mafia calabraise la
n'drangheta se fait plus discrète mais
est beaucoup plus puissante était
l'unique hama le procureur vedette
italien nicola gratteri affirme que la
'ndrangheta est la seule mafia présente
sur tous les continents
là où elle est la plus présente tout y
est ils adorent cette mafia s'appuie sur
cette cellule en ontario deux d'entre
elles oeuvrent attentes de b une ville
en apparence sans histoire
antonio nicaso qui réside à toronto
vient de publier ce livre sur la n20
guetta de l'escrinet josé pedro diaz et
est considéré par la justice italienne
comme un important membre d'une des deux
cellules de la n'dranghetta de temps
devait il a été arrêté par la police
italienne pendant qu'il visitait sa
calabre natale en 2011
son procès a lieu actuellement dans une
salle de cours où lui et d'autres
accusés sont séparés des avocats et du
juge par une vitre pare balles dans ce
procès la justice italienne a déposé des
conversations secrètes enregistrés dans
une buanderie de ce centre commercial du
sud de la calabre entre lui et un des
plus importants dirigeants de
l'organisation mafieuse guissepe comisso
dit le maître l'émission enquête avait
déjà révélé l'an dernier l'existence de
ces enregistrements
selon les procureurs affecté au dossier
le simple fait que puts aisée et hulk
c'est un dirigeant de la n'dranghetta de
si haut rang démontre son implication
dans l'organisation criminelle
je vais conteste son avocat italien m
armando jay roach et a déclaré à radio
canada cette semaine que bruce aisés est
un honorable citoyen qui a toujours
envoyé de l'argent à sa famille en
italien les fruits de son travail
parfois l'hiver à moins 30 degrés
atteints de b qui n'a jamais commis de
crime
le verdict dans cette cause est attendue
au cours de l'été trois autres citoyens
de tonnes de b d'origine calabraise sont
visés par des mandats d'arrestation de
la police italienne
mais ils ne peuvent être extradé puisque
le canada ne reconnaît pas la loi anti
associations mafieuses italiennes
frustrer certains procureurs italiens
n'hésite pas à comparer l'ontario à une
colonie pénale servant de refuge à de
présumés mafieux en cavale à du canada
montréal